how do you think will virtual reality
tie in the future of Transportation
which you are working on thank you well
maybe we're in a simulation right now
[Applause]
yeah seriously some of this feels like
that yeah I think it is gonna from what
I've heard of oculus rift and and some
the other immersive technologies that
it's quite transformative you really
feel like you're there and and then when
you come out of it it feels like reality
isn't real so I think we'll see probably
less physical movement in the future as
a result of the virtual reality stuff
yeah and when we come out of what we're
here now into this virtual reality will
think it's real I mean it's like what
well I mean I mean there's some
interesting things here on the virtual
reality front I mean just and on the
whole notion of a simulation which is
that if you just if you extrapolate into
the future and say well how good let's
say well video games be in a hundred or
two hundred or thousand years from now
if if there's continued improvement and
you're in a full-body haptic see if suit
with a sort of surround vision and you
know you it becomes beyond a certain
resolution indistinguishable from
reality if and they were likely to be
there like three millions maybe maybe
billions of such simulations so then
what are the odds that we're actually in
base reality isn't it one in billions is
it I mean give I can give the counter
but I'd rather you give the
counter-argument I it obviously this
feels real but but it mean I mean it
seems unlikely to be real